Cockroaches are nature’s most successful
crash test dummies.
Roaches don’t swerve or slow down
when they encounter walls.
And it's not because they can’t see them.
It’s because walls are no obstacle.
These unstoppable insects
hit a wall and keep on running--up.
They use the force of the collision
to launch themselves vertically,
a process that takes just 75 msec.
Now, researchers are taking a page
from the cockroach playbook
to create their own wall-climbing bot.
Most mobile robots deal with obstacles
by sensing and then dodging around them.
But this decision-making process
slows them down and limits their ability
to perform high-speed tasks.
So scientists developed a sensorless,
cockroach-sized robot
with a soft exoskeleton and six legs
It, too, can shift from
horizontal to vertical movement
by simply crashing into a wall.
The big secret to its success
is its tiny size—a mere 16 grams.
As animals increase in size,
they hit with more energy during collisions,
making them more susceptible to injury.
The researchers calculated
that only animals weighing less than 1 kg
would be able to use the cockroaches’
head-first collision technique for climbing.
Sad news for real crash test dummies,
who had better keep buckling up.